heath is going to start us off from
columbus ohio this hour
hey heath how are you hey i'm doing well
guys thanks for taking my call sure man
what's up
um so i'm calling today to ask for your
guidance on
uh my uh in-law and
my my parents-in-law uh kind of the
relationship we have now so
about five years ago my mother-in-law
inherited
you know unknown amount of money i'm
guessing it's probably a couple hundred
thousand dollars
and my father-in-law invested that uh
with eyes wide open
in the oil market took a bunch of stuff
out on margin
and this weird thing happened a couple
months ago where the stock market tanked
so they pretty much lost everything
again i'm unclear exactly
what they had and what they lost but
they now tell us things like oh you know
we can't afford to pay for cable
we can't afford to pay for gasoline in
our car to come visit you and
they value a lot on the phrase we're
retired
uh they're in their late 60s 65 67
and basically refusing to go back to
work
you know they had minimal savings and my
wife and i are just really struggling
with
how how do we handle this um as as their
children we
obviously we want to support them but
we've got three small kids we just
bought a house
and you know we're really unclear um
on what we should be doing as as their
children to
guide them um during this time heath i
like you
i like you too well i appreciate that i
i i like you
now that we've got that settled man
here's the thing he's not taking an
emotional approach and i have to
approach
a victim approach but it's a it's
somebody i can tell cares and loves for
his in-laws
and hurts for him at the same time he
lives in a reality that he's got a wife
and three kids and they're working
together to raise a house and
that's a tough situation other than the
passive aggressive grenades
have they actually asked directly for
money
they have yeah there was one occasion uh
right after everything hit
um with the you know the covet and the
stock market crash
um for their property taxes which were
past due so they needed money for that
um
and so i you know i quickly started
looking up how to handle
these types of questions and of course i
found you so i'm really grateful like
youtube everything that you had about
in-laws and you know not saving for
retirement and so i tried walking
through him
and you know getting him to acknowledge
that hey you know my wife and i might
have to go back to work
and that just went like right over his
head he was just well hey
either you have the money or you don't
um so i didn't give it to him
and i did have the money and that's
that's kind of really where
again this the struggle for me in my
wife is that you know
i make a good living um we've been
blessed to you know i come
my side of the family they've been very
generous with so what is your what is
your household
what is your household income uh about
170.
okay so you are killing it and um
they're probably somewhat aware of that
you understand that when he made that
statement that that was a that was a
statement that says i am
entitled to your stuff yeah i don't like
that statement at all
and that's that seems to be the
underlying attitude
but i think i think that's you know
that's
where my wife and i are there our fear
is is that hey they're just going to
throw their hands up
and whatever happens rely on the fact
that
you know hey you know my my son-in-law
and his wife who stays at home with
their kids like
you know at worst comes to worst they'll
just provide for us
and i got a list of priorities and my
father-in-law is not you know the
highest of those
i'm telling you i like this guy dave i
like this guy you can make fun of me
okay i like this guy so um
yeah um i think there's two
or three levels of help that you can
look at
obviously one you don't want to put them
on the dole where you support them the
rest of your life because and they don't
address the situation
that's an unacceptable process making
sure they have food
yeah yeah that's fine making sure they
have shelter that's fine
but i'm probably going to if they come
at you again for money
i'm probably going to have some real
calm in person if possible discussions
with
the two of them this sounds something
like this
we love you and we are not going to
support you
ongoing you will you will always have
food
but you're able-bodied and uh you need
to get on a written game plan
and if before i give you money again i'm
going to do a full
audit of your financial situation i'm
going to know where every dollar is
and i'm going to know what your income
is and we're gonna do a budget together
and you're gonna be on a budget that i
approve or i'm not giving you any money
and if you don't wanna do that i
completely understand but those are my
terms
and i'm gonna i'm gonna recommend that
your wife be there with you in that
conversation absolutely
absolutely yeah for sure yeah and uh so
that they don't come back later
and you know i'll give you uh let me
tell you what i think will happen
based on this comment that he made
earlier i think you're gonna get the
exact same reaction
and they're just going to blow you off
in which case they are saying
i don't need your help and so you don't
have to give them help
or my pride cost more than my my desire
to not be hungry yeah
and i'm entitled to your money and i'm
gonna be a part of it he's embarrassed
that
uh as to what happened yeah we ought to
be that was a really dumb play
he views going back to work as you know
a failure on his part
it it is that's exactly what it is and
the quicker
a grown-up can recognize hey i screwed
up and now i've got to go make it right
yeah and make a grown-up not being
entitled to my son-in-law's
like and taking money out of my kids and
my grandkids
because let me just tell you it wasn't
the stock market that got him okay
the stock market didn't get him he was
playing oil he's playing commodities
market
this is the most volatile market you
have a better chance of hitting the
roulette wheel in vegas than you do
doing what he was doing
that's what he was doing and so and when
what happened was
oil got him because oil went to a
negative not the stock market
the oil market did the commodities
market debt we had tankers sitting off
shore full of oil they wouldn't off-load
them because the oil was worth
negative amounts per barrel for a few
weeks there
because no one was driving and all the
supply dried up
all the use dried up the demand for
gasoline dried up
and he he set himself up by playing an
ultra high risk play
whether he realized it or not and it
caught you know he went to vegas and
blew his wife's inheritance
that's what he did well he realized that
we talked to him about it
you know what a mistake was i put him in
touch with my financial planner
and they all told him not to do it he
refused to listen
to anybody and you know
when you do all that every one of those
things now
limits your ability to help him you
can't help him
you can because now you're if you're if
you give him money you're just
participating in his fantasy land
participating in his delusions your
financing is crazy
now if you want to buy them some food
and send them a bag of groceries or two
over there i'm fine with that
but these people need an overhaul of
their behaviors
i don't think they're going to let you
give them that if they do i will be
stone cold
shocked